the Alien franchise has made an
indelible mark on film history and
future but with prequels and sequels
expanding the original story over a span
of several decades it can be hard to
entangle what's really going on here
what's the alien movie saga really about
let's explore the alien movie story
begins when a proto human on earth
drinks a deadly poison that kills him
and dissolves his body into strands of
human DNA which since then dosed into
the water supply several million years
later dr. Elizabeth sure believed she
has found a map and an invitation to the
planet where these proto humans
originated she calls them engineers and
she wrongly assumes they want to meet
their children sure and the scientific
crew are hired by the Weyland
corporation to find the engineers on
planet LV two to three and after a great
deal of trouble they arrive but the
engineers are all dead their spacecraft
is filled with jars of toxic black goo
corresponding to egg-like sacs a begin
to open when signs of life appear yes
dr. Shaw finds her engineers a lifelong
passion bordering on obsession but what
she didn't expect to find was that the
engineers had set a course to Earth with
the intention of wiping out the human
race they had created the engineers
never have their chance as they
themselves are wiped out by an ever
evolving neo morph the predecessor to
the xenomorph scene later in the series
megalomaniacal Android Dave decides to
take up the engineers mantle and infects
the human crew big things have small
beginnings after chaos destruction and
an encounter with the revived engineer
who proves his hostility toward humans
David and dr. Shaw escape to the
engineers home show us new obsession is
understanding what the engineers plan to
kill all the humans was greed one of the
human foibles and led the engineers to
one to eliminate us it's Pizza Whelan's
greedy obsession for immortality that
drives him to create the Android David
who eventually surpasses his maker and
winds up creating a xenomorph as we know
it that the engineers know will come to
suspect that human behavior would be the
universe's eventual destruction all
signs point to yes dr. Shaw never
actually makes it to the engineer's home
planet which she and David have been
calling paradise instead David kills her
and drops a black goo on the thriving
planet he cultivates Animorph eggs
sends out a welcoming signal to try and
attract new life-forms to what is now
his planet the Covenant has a colonizer
craft set out for one of the few
remaining known habitable planets in the
universe our guys six along with an
entire ecosystem on board the covering
crew is awakened from hypersleep years
early and on a hunch they divert from
their course to check out the signal
coming from the unnamed planet a human
being out there where there can't be any
humans a hidden planet that turns up out
of nowhere and just happens to be
perfect for us it's too good to be true
so much of the aliens story is based on
humans terraforming faraway planets
because the earth was either becoming or
already was uninhabitable thanks to
climate change or more the privileged
few humans who could escape a planet did
and with apparent gusto it didn't seem
to bother them that they will spend
decades of their lives in hypersleep to
get to these planets and star rebuilding
without these humans looking for new
places to colonize the xenomorph would
never have found this perfect host to
propagate his own species with a little
help from david david has been
engineering a new form of the xenomorph
a perfect organism that he can finally
test on human subjects with the crew on
board the Covenant is walter the newest
model Android whose sensitise kantor
parts is up to no good
when David finds out covenant has an
entire colony of hundreds of humans is a
battle to stop him before he
commandeered the ship for his own
purposes when he does we start to
realize what the engineers wanted to
destroy their human creation like their
ancestors humans also decided to play
God and created synthetic life in their
own image David's god complex mirrors
his Creator Wayland's and now david has
created a monster in the alien vision of
the future Android technology mirrors
human emotional developments David and
Walter are different models of clone
androids and Prometheus and covenant
designed by Peter Weyland for different
means to different ends david was a
special creation made to match Whelan's
great intelligence and one day surpasses
he is the closest thing to a son I will
ever have unfortunately he's he's not
human he will never die
Walter was created to be a faithful
companion to its human counterparts a
protector and source of support as Alien
begins it's been 16 years since we left
David in the spaceship covenant a
salvaging team on the ship Nostromo
answers a distress call on planet lv-426
even though they aren't equipped for a
rescue mission a Haier second too late
and the Ripley figures out the distress
call is actually a warning but one of
her crew Cain has already been infected
by a xenomorph facehugger breaking
quarantine protocols Cain is allowed
back on board where the alien hatches
and rigs bloody havoc Ashe a crew member
who's secretly an Android receives a
communique from people at the company
who wants him to bring the creature back
alive
no matter the human cost here the
Android Ashe is nowhere near as
sophisticated as either David or Walter
presumably because these toys ended up
being dangerously advanced but Ashe was
also a danger to humans especially once
he got his marching orders to bring the
xenomorph back alive disobeying orders
ripley under crew hun the monster and
eventually kill it as one of the most
memorable survivors put to screen Ripley
strikes a perfect balance between
strength and vulnerability as well as
professionalism and competence even
though she is met with disbelief when
she first discusses a reality of the
xenomorph she refuses to be gaslighted
Ripley and the cat Jones are the only
survivors who end this portion of the
alien saga tucked safely in hypersleep
waiting to be found by another ship
interestingly Jones was an excellent
first alert system since he tried to
warn multiple people about the presence
of the alien on board the Nostromo and
like Ripley nobody listened to him at
first but Jones would go on to survive
the series longer than any other human
character outside of our well-known
heroine you think that when one of the
deadliest and most virulent creatures to
ever exist surfaces the logical thing to
do would be to exterminate it especially
if it has the power to destroy every
planet to touch us but because of
corporate greed opportunistic humans
attempt to capitalize financially off
the creature at the expense of other
humans with less powerful positions why
didn't you warn them Burke the arrogance
of man we see throughout this series is
a scathing indictment of an obsession
with violence and killing there are a
few women in much of the alien saga but
it's the women who ultimately fight
against these deadly obsessions at the
start of aliens Ripley has drifted in
hypersleep for 57 years before she's
awakened and ends up on the military
vessel Sulaco unfortunately the Sulaco
is under instruction to return to lv-426
where Hadleys hope a human colony has
suddenly stopped responding to all
communication ripley is in severe
post-traumatic stress which turns into
grief when she finds out her daughter
died on earth or she was in hypersleep
were still her claims about the alien
monster with acid for blood on taken
seriously enough to stop the mission
because those things gets down here then
that will be all do you think it's so
important you could just kiss all that
goodbye on lv-426
the Sulaco crew and Ripley searched a
seemingly abandoned colony and find a
new xenomorph nest the eggs have already
hatched and used the entire colony as
incubators with the exception of one
survivor a young girl named news news is
a same age Ripley's daughter was when
she first left Earth
so Ripley is immediately protective of
her once the Salar Coast military crew
realizes he no more threats is as
horrific as Ripley insisted they tried
to escape but as an alien once again
corporates and military greed leads to
sabotage this time from Burke who's
determined to preserve a xenomorph
specimen he and the creature are both
defeated and Ripley survives joined by
newts Jones the cat's corporal Hicks and
the torso of Android Bishop who proves
to be a portrait of empathy one in which
we can see shades of earlier Walter the
reveal that ripley's daughter has died
becomes Keitha character it explains why
she's so protective of the women in
their orbits going forward especially
young girls even by the time she's
hybrid Ripley in resurrection she has a
fierce maternal side showed in the way
she shields her Android call as well as
a continued deep distress of the company
man when hybrid Ripley has an alien baby
who imprints on her she's horrified and
disgusted by the monster but at the same
time feels that connection and weeps
openly when she has to kill it surely
after Ripley enters hypersleep in the
Sulaco a fire breaks out killing
everyone else on board and shooting her
pod into space it lands on penal colony
fiorina 161 but a Sulaco shuttle also
crashes but Ripley is in the sole
survivor a xenomorph had also made it
and that impregnated her before ejecting
her onto Fiorina 161 the penal colony
has essentially been abandoned by the
people who created it
the weyland-yutani corporation until
they find out that a live xenomorph on
board and the Ripley is carrying an
alien fetus in her chest because it is a
present planet run by convicts there are
no weapons to fight the monster other
than a steel forged that hasn't been
used in decades Ripley and the prisoners
still finally managed to kill the Lucy
no morph again a huge human cost
when weyland-yutani emissaries arrive
they're headed by Michael Bishop the
human template for the Android Bishop
but Ripley knows better than to trust
company member now and she throws
herself into a pit of molten steel so
nobody can try to weaponize alien
monster within her Ripley's already
sacrificed so much in fighting this
creature he or she gives up the last
thing she has left because humans can't
seem to leave well enough alone when it
comes to universe's troying acid blooded
creatures Alien Resurrection continues a
story 200 years later when the United
systems military is still trying to
recreate a functioning xenomorph aboard
the USS Auriga using Ripley's melded
human and alien DNA were covered from
fiorina 161 new crops of military
Sciences tinker with her code to clone
the xenomorph they've engineered a
hybrid version of Ripley who has green
nails acid blood and vague memories from
the original Ripley who died centuries
before the scientists have also finally
created a working xenomorph but like
Ripley it's not the same creature it
once was it swelled smarter and
understands English so we're a fast
learner a salvage team from the ship
Betty boss here we go with human cargo
that will be used to create more
monsters for military mice a new Android
call is on her own mission to kill the
hybrid Ripley before she can give the
military the Queen that was just stating
in a chest she fails her mission but
Cole's role here is also to show how
Android progression in the series has
reached near human status with a machine
who's more human than inhuman Ripley
attempts to kill the Queen before she
gives birth but is also too late however
the Queen doesn't give birth to eggs as
a past Queen's half
said it gives birth to a fully formed
alien with many of Ripley's features a
huge baby alien kills the Queen thanking
Ripley is as actual mother and Ripley is
forced to kill her baby while the Auriga
crashes into Earth
Ripley finally makes it back to our home
planet as sort of a mystery injury or
myself
long before the alien prequels introduce
an ear morph the creature evolved over
the course of each original film both in
physicality and intelligence while this
evolution is confusing at first by alien
covenant we learned David as the father
of the xenomorph as we know it from
alien and beyond the black ooze
cultivated by the engineers with a
biological weapon with the ability to
mutate as host hence why we seized
several different versions of the
monster over the course of Prometheus
and alien covenant the xenomorph is a
perfect killing machine and one of the
sad lessons never learned by humans was
to leave the thing alone it cannot be
tamed it can only be killed and even
that proves an almost impossible feat
for hundreds of years even though hybrid
Ripley appears to kill the last of the
xenomorph who knows whether they have
persisted on another planet out in the
universe waiting for a meets out to
arrive and play host check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]